[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast
live stream q a section number 44
where we meet your cues with our a's
it sounds lewd only if that's where your
mind defaults
i don't think so you don't think so no i
think jason is yeah
a little bit lewd a little bit i didn't
intend it as loot just
so we're clear all right uh oh hello
hi um we
will start with a few questions uh from
the last episode
and then pick up a question from discord
server
and then get to your questions from the
last hour
all right uh hi bretton heather thanks
for answering my ayahuasca question last
week
you mentioned that humans aren't the
only species that expresses gender
what other species also do it and how
please
uh so i thought this just warranted a uh
a
quick mention that um
the way that i've been defining gender
and the way that it fits
for me uh with all of the manifestations
that i've seen
um people use it is that it is
effectively the behavioral expression of
sex
and that in every animal that's
non-human and all the non-human animals
um
that what we call that is sex role and
so
there are um there are sex roles that
species from uh you know anemone fish to
sea horses
to antelope to elephant seals to
dolphins and umbrella birds
um you know have and they are sex
specific
uh so um we don't call it gender in
other species
uh but it is it is if it if if gender is
the behavioral expression of sex
then then you're going to have
you're going to have that happen anytime
you've got um
behavior which is certainly all mammals
and birds and
probably all vertebrates and a
tremendous number of inverts as well
tremendous number of
insects so i would um i have been
defining
gender differently i've said it as the
software of sex in which case
gender will be found
in um birds and mammals
to a substantial degree but but
differing degrees within those clades
and not much found outside of them so i
guess
there's a question about which
definition of gender we're going with
now
i think that's i mean that's that's
interesting because those um
i like both of those definitions um
behavioral expression of sex which is
the one that i've been saying for years
and
have you know written into pieces that
i've written and you're saying the
software of sex and they are
overlapping but not completely and um
and so they do they do have different
ramifications
for how you view say uh the stereotyped
lordosis behavior of a female
lizard um uh you know is that is that
gender or not it would be by my
definition but not by yours
um but it but the overlap i think is um
pretty much perfect when it comes to
humans like we have
no variance so just so people know why
we're
the difference is immense between these
two definitions because most
um critters will not have gender because
most critters don't meet their parents
and therefore whatever um sex role
they have will be programmed in at a
genetic level
if behavior is stereotyped um then it
doesn't count um
as gender by your definition right and
so the
point about it being you know if you
accept that it is the software of sex
and the point
is software is vastly more flexible than
hardware you know in a lizard that
doesn't meet its parents
and exhibits the stereotyped behaviors
um
you know there isn't a lot of
flexibility because in order for the
creature to be functional that stuff had
to be written in and the fact that it is
written in is amazing in so many
creatures but
um but the vast majority will have
nothing that we would call
um software it's much more like you know
maybe firmware it's programmed by
the genes and all but unalterable
next question is a reference to holly
mathnerd wrote last time
which is what's your favorite star trek
series
and why is it deep space nine and this
person writes
i am paying you twenty dollars to watch
the magnificent ferengi ferengi
i'm just is it frankie episode of star
trek deep space nine season six
episode ten so um i'm sure it's better
than cuties
i'll give it that sight unseen i i feel
confident that that will also be my
judgment now we've actually
we've heard um indirectly from a lot of
people now that uh
uh that you were wrong uh that the idea
that this was just sort of a workplace
drama
is exactly wrong and actually one of the
analyses i saw
reminded me of um it sounds i know
nothing about the show i literally know
nothing about it i've never seen one
um but that it reminded me a little bit
of what um actually bob trivers had told
us with regard to why when we went to
grad school we should go to a place of
museum
one of the reasons being that when
you're at a big
an important research museum people from
all over the world with different
research questions and different
backgrounds and different biases and
expectations and hypotheses come through
and so the idea of a space station
workplace drama is as a place where all
the rest of the world comes through when
you get to interact with them
strikes me as potentially the reason
that it could be
exactly as good as many people including
holly mathnerd and perhaps ragnar of the
desert
i think it is i don't think i said that
deep space nine was a workplace drama i
think
maybe um maybe the next generation
is a workplace drama i said that deep
space nine suffered from nothing ever
happening
oh um but in any case in any case
apparently things do happen enough that
people are are captivated by by this
series
okay so there it is there it is uh
hey both thanks so much for your work
i've been puzzling for a while why there
are almost zero
woke debates held anywhere you'd think
they would want to get their messages
out
thanks tim they can't do it though
they'd be terrible at it
um yeah they it is inherently
a terrible position because the thing is
um
maybe debate is the wrong term but uh a
dialectic is predicated on the idea that
there is some truth to discover and
wokeness is predicated on the idea that
there isn't and so it's a
it's a mismatch um i will
sooner uh want to engage in sword
fighting of course they i'm sure they
can't do that either
right um right yes yes no doing things
is not their strong suit no
destroying things doing things and
thinking things both not so much
right so i will point people again to
the
um the braver angels podcast with
john wood jr and um
bob woodson and i don't know this is
duke newsom
i don't know i hope i have it right i
hope i have not embarrassingly pulled a
name from somewhere else
i've done that before here well i i hope
i didn't but in any case
if you look for bob woodson you will
find i think it's
duke newsom as the counterpart and
there is a very good debate between a an
idw
style uh person in bob woodson
and duke on the other side as
a high up in blm and john wood jr
as moderator and it does give you a
sense for how these things go and i must
say
um it goes about as as you would expect
well i mean interestingly actually our
introduction to john wood jr was
when he moderated a debate um put on by
the
bridging the divide i think it's called
organization
um based here in portland uh between us
and to people who were representing the
the woke side
and um there is audio and poor quality
video of that
too um somewhere out there in the world
um
and i mean john it it was our
introduction to john he's extraordinary
as a moderator in that sort of situation
and you know doesn't let anyone sink but
lets people think themselves when when
that's what's going to happen
when that is warranted yes
all right next question last question
final question
from episode 43 a great deal of
businesses or this is more of a comet
i think a great deal of businesses here
in wisconsin seem to be owned and run by
republicans
in my experience those of us who are
left of center have had to tread
carefully sometimes even fearful of
repercussions for speaking up
many of us have to listen to far-right
libtard type rhetoric by superiors and
are subject to them making business
decisions based on their anirand beliefs
it's intense and impacts us as much as
those who lament being on the right
while working at liberally owned
companies
right question mark uh
yeah yeah i imagine it is so this is um
i i think this is fascinating actually
because um
we know you know as as liberals who were
in academia for many years
um it is well documented that
anecdotally there is no denying it
uh that academia is so liberal that to
be conservative there would be very very
hard indeed
uh and um i think the same is true of
media
and of hollywood and of many other um
kinds of organizations as well
but that small business might well um
have the opposite bias
and basically what is being what sharon
is pointing to here
is that anytime you're in a a
tiny minority uh where the majority is
so certain of
the widespread acceptance of its
politics um
it's it's hard to sit on your hands
and it can make you stronger it'll make
you better at actually
responding to the arguments from the
other side because you're surrounded by
them all the time i think part of what's
going on
on the woke left is that these are
people largely
you know the privileged among them were
schooled in colleges and universities
where there has been effectively no
conservative presence for so long
they've never heard the arguments
against
uh what they're saying now of course i
would also argue that we
as you know actual liberals uh would
push back against the woke nonsense but
they're increasingly silencing us too
and we're you know we are
ever rarer at universities as well um to
wit you know being in exile along with
many other people who are just
leaving because um there's no place for
us you just point to me and say two wit
two which is four half widths yes um but
so uh what more which than most people
have it's not bad i wasn't gonna
complain i just wanted to just
point out noted in passing sure um so
i would say um i have been trying to
catalyze something that i have
occasionally called
uh the founding of your other left
and the idea that other
so the thing is i'm now seeing
increasing awareness
on the right and amongst um many
people i respect on the right a
relief and a
happiness at discovering that there are
people
uh who will proudly proclaim themselves
as on the left who are making sense and
are not crazy
and so in any case um
i do think that this is a slow battle
but that what really needs to happen
is those of us who are part of this uh
this old
intellectual left tradition that still
you know has
uh pockets of of of life
that those of us who belong to that need
to be clear enough about who we are and
why we
are there that it does begin to dawn on
all of those who have been
dismissing the left you know with this
mind-numbing libtard
uh rhetoric um that they are they become
aware
that it actually it is not so simple and
you know many people
ben shapiro greg gutfeld tucker carlson
all of these folks have registered that
actually there's a necessity of the left
and what i'm hoping ultimately and it's
not totally absent
right the the vestiges are there um it's
just being drowned out by something
that isn't left at all it's quite a
liberal
but ultimately we need to have a
discussion
about what the left got
right what the right got right and how
we are now
living the benefits of the tension
between these two things
um and frankly i think people will be
surprised if they do
an honest accounting of just how much
the left has been correct about
historically speaking
now one of one of the things in what you
said that's so important
is the idea of tension that um one of
the many reasons that utopia is
a a dangerous fiction and can never
happen
is that any versions of utopia i've ever
heard of
imagine a life without strife for life
without tension and
tension is the thing that both provides
meaning
and a force to strive against and
and allows things from descending into
total chaos on either side of the
spectrum and that's what we're seeing as
the you know for instance as the
the protests on the street are allowed
to do uh whatever they want with no
pushback at all
from the would-be leadership it's just
revealing itself ever more with every
week
as uh more insane and you know it's not
that it's i think becoming more insane
it's just able to reveal itself as
more and more of the insane thing that
it's always been yeah um and in fact i
did not get around to showing in the
first hour
that data was collected by actually an
organization that's
based here in portland has a washington
dc office
data was collected that reveals that
there is essentially
very little support ah here we have it
do you want to show it i'm sure
zachary um all right so
entity dhm research
um scroll down take take a look at some
of the charts
not that one keep going okay
so uh approval of the protests
is um you need to show that you need to
scroll up a little more there you go
um so this is oregon oregon oregonians
who were surveyed
uh disagree 51 51 of oregonians who were
surveyed disagreed that president trump
has done an appropriate job with regard
to response to the protests
um but 39 or disagree strongly rather
um but if you include disagree strongly
and somewhat disagree
um a majority of oregonians
feel that trump governor brown and mayor
wheeler
all have done a pretty poor job pretty
poor job
yeah and uh and then the response in
terms of portland police officers is far
more
um far more varied yes it is and it's a
confusing one i wouldn't know how to
answer that because i don't think the
portland police have done a very they
haven't been allowed
yeah keep going some of these are hard
to interpret at a first pass um
um so uh scroll
up a little more oh sorry yeah uh
approval level of portland protests
um in oregon um 52
strongly disagree with the protests yeah
so tri-county is
uh basically the portland metro area
it's gonna be what multnomah
clackamas in washington yeah okay um
even in the willamette
valley valley which is the bigger bigger
area that we live in but you know
when you include strongly disagree and
somewhat disagree you have a strong
majority
even in the tri-county area um that are
saying yeah these protests are not
anything that we are interested in
playing along with anymore
we're going okay um oh ongoing protests
are helpful or harmful to black
portlanders
um so this is blackport letters
answering isn't it or no no okay
i think this is two okay yeah two race
relations right okay
um so there is um
31 percent believe that the protests are
very harmful to
black portlanders um 17
say somewhat harmful 38 believe it is
very harmful to race relations 15 say
somewhat harmful
um efforts to make police reforms 32
percent very
17 somewhat so a lot of skepticism about
these protests keep going uh here we go
are the protests violent right of the
choice
yeah um 56 percent of people think
they're mostly violent
which i would agree they are if they
reliably turn to violence they are
mostly violent
it really i mean this is going to sound
clintonian but it kind of depends on
what your definition of mostly is
as you know has all of these things
right i agree but if
you're if you're doing a kind of like
ethogram
and you know every 30 seconds looking
and going like i'm going to record
violent or not not violent okay the next
30 seconds violent are not not violent
but then you get then you get garbage
then you get the 93
peaceful 93 peaceful so what does mostly
violent
mean you know but if you take it by day
it depends on your your interval of
recording right like
how many days of protest have been
violent oh mostly violent actually but
yeah
this is a test of something different so
i agree you can define these things and
you can get any answer you want but
that's
part of the point is that that's exactly
what's been done to us and when you ask
people you know common parlance is this
mostly peaceful or mostly violent 56
of it say mostly violent by whatever the
intuitive definition of this is and i
think
they're absolutely right so um anyway
we don't need to go all the way through
this report and um
we should probably get back to the
questions yeah so let's let's do that
oops
um okay next question from the discord
server and then we will get to the
questions from today
you've discussed historical examples of
fascism and communism
maoist china the soviet union nazi
germany venezuela
chile etc are there historical examples
where the madness was defeated before it
became catastrophic
from these what lessons can we learn and
apply to our current circumstances
um it's this is a very hard question
to answer they knew this was going to be
hard apparently douglas mario was
asked this question recently on
trigonometry and
yeah also had a hard time with it i
think i think the reason that it's hard
is that if something avoids being
what um one fears that it is going to
turn into
then there's no way to distinguish
between whether it was never headed to
be that and people were catastrophizing
over nothing or whether they
successfully
um beat back the danger the history
it will be hard to write the history
that says we beat this thing
before it got bad yeah and there will be
at least as many histories written that
say it wasn't the thing they thought it
was going to be
yeah and you know there's also the
possibility in some cases
that something that was headed to some
place very bad
went somewhere bad but it could have
been way worse and so how do you rank
that
um so i i don't know i don't i mean just
in terms of the actual question i don't
i don't know enough history
to come up with um things that might
might look like what we're describing
now
uh but i imagine that there would be
lessons to be learned yeah
it's a great question yeah how the
methodology is the tough part
okay religions and secular faiths uh
such as social justice are
sub-categories of one socio-cognitive
phenomenon
narrative dog was dogmas united group
against others
excuse me dogma's united group against
others with shared epistemology morality
and central narrative
thoughts
some categories of socio-cognitive
phenomenon
dogmas united group um
yeah i mean i think loosely speaking
that's about
right and you know it's true um
i'm not sure so i guess i wondered
dogma's united group against others who
shared epistemology morality and central
narrative
i wonder that might be the the three
things
that are actually defining um i'd want
to think more about whether or not you
could simplify those or does that
collapse to
one or two uh variables or is
are there more things um that
define what a dogma is that are not on
that list i'm not sure
yeah i'm not sure if either thing is
missing or if it can be simplified and
it may also be
in some sense um
overdrawn because we see the same
phenomenon inside of scientific
disciplines right a particular school of
thought will take over
um and it's not entirely clear to me
that it doesn't actually
share morality with the schools of
thought that are
driven out that it just wins temporarily
some
uh some game over publications or
something
um well but maybe i mean the argument
then i think would be that that doesn't
it's not
no no it's actually you're right i was
going to say that's not a secular faith
but
this person is defining a dogma as a
bigger group
than in relations and secular faiths
that's those are subcategories
yeah yeah
um no i actually i think you're right i
think morality at least
um is a sometimes uh variable but not
always
and definitely one dog i guess another
although it's possible based on the
way the question is written that the
moralities don't have to differ right
you can be united
with your um your fellows in a doctor it
doesn't have to be the thing that
defines you against others it just has
to be the thing that
helps you define you know in group yeah
yeah okay next question accepting that
the plural of anecdote isn't data
what role can or may anecdotes play if
any in analysis
particularly repeated and or highly
translatable anecdotes or analyzing
qualitative rather than quantitative
circumstances
i wanted to pull something up actually
if you want to riff from it i want to
pull something up sure
the the sense
of the danger of anecdotes is
way overdrawn and in some sense it is
designed
by the same people who are constantly
wielding
you know the data is king what do the
data say
um data-driven research these sorts of
things which sound right you know it
sounds sophisticated
to be skeptical of anecdotes and it is
it sounds very sophisticated to say that
the multiple
of anecdote is not data on the other
hand
first of all in a complex system when
you do observation
you are observing anecdotes that's how
you get to a hypothesis that's worthy of
test
and so
let's just say if anecdote exists in the
observational phase
of scientific research it's perfectly
legitimate and
it just simply travels by a different
name
so in any case there are certain things
that are deployed to keep
a powerful group powerful and this is
one of them
so i would say correlation implies
causation when it's preceded by a
properly predictive hypothesis
despite what you've been told and
anecdote is a very important source of
information about a system it is not in
and of itself
a test of a hypothesis yep
though it can be used as a spot check
right you can have a hypothesis for some
reason
and then you can check it against the
anecdotes in your head and say
actually i don't believe that hypothesis
because i know six instances in which
they would have gone a different way
each of which were anecdotes
you can falsify with anecdote um so yeah
what i wanted to say i can't
find the actual uh paper but there's a
reading that i used to give um from
barbara smutz
who's uh who was on my doctoral
committee and one of the important
researchers in baboon behavior and
specifically
who focused on female baboon behavior
and in her book sex and friendship and
baboons
she wrote a bit about basically
the the kinds of data that you take in
the field and so i just went looking
into my methodology behavioral
methodology lectures that i would give
to students before i sent them out to
try to
start to become animal behaviorists i
don't find it there but
um there she has a sort of a taxonomy
of of course the kind of thing that you
can see over and over again between
individuals
and also keep track of the context in
which you saw them are the things that
we look for when we are going to
apply statistical analysis to the data
but there are two other categories of
things and i don't i just don't have it
in my head and i can't pull it up here
um some of which happen occasionally
but under such dissimilar circumstances
that you couldn't that even though you
might have 10
instances you still can't apply
statistics to them because you know that
they're the same but they're not
the same enough and then some of which
you may actually just see once or twice
and so there is no expectation
that you would actually um be able to
apply statistics and therefore you know
you can
and if you can't apply statistics we
basically don't call it
data except that and you know if it's
only one offer too often we tend to call
it anecdote
but over in um trying to understand
behavior land over in animal behavior
land
the rarest things are often the most
explanatory and certainly the most
exciting
so you know we know that chimps
sometimes wage war on one another
because jane goodall saw it happen once
over an extended period of days but it's
one i think it was a
i think it was a fissioning group um
that then drew a line
in the sand effectively and fighted with
one another fighted fight it
and then and then fought with one
another um and
similarly you will find um you know just
other kinds of territorial takeovers or
sexual takeovers or
um either between groups or the
replacement of an alpha
or um or defense um
by females by usurping male against
infanticide you know these sorts of
things happen rarely enough
that you may not have enough for data
but once you see it if you're out there
trying to understand
animals um you then have a very
different model of what it is that's
happening and what's driving them it's
the rare event that often is explanatory
and no we can't plug it into stats but
um it will be the thing that informs
our understanding maybe more than and
today
they've foraged again of course they did
right once upon a time
back before we became so stupid we used
to know this right
you still talking about us no we we are
trying to opt out of stupid it's
sometimes a full-time job but
um but you know it used to be that
natural history
was understood to be a scientifically
valid pursuit and in fact a very
important one
and the fact is the you know the uh
data-driven science people have among
other things they've driven out theory
and they've driven out
um natural history so it used to be you
saw something
remarkable like i once saw what i
believed to be a woodpecker riding on
the back of a crow
what it was amazing where uh
in a deep lake in uh in sun lakes in
eastern washington
um but in any case
i also saw a moose there right
in in the desert right so here's the
thing there used to be a thing called a
natural history note
where you saw something it was
unmistakable what you saw and you
documented as much about
what it was that you saw and then you
just simply reported it so that
everybody would have the benefit of
effectively having seen the same thing
well actually i published one of these i
published one of these
um with regard to let's see i could have
done two which one did i publish
ah with regard to my frogs in madagascar
at one point i'm sitting there watching
this marked population of
i've tattooed them so i know who all the
individuals are and i've got a couple of
fights going on
with the very active fascinating little
poisonous frogs
um and up from the leaf later comes a
boa and
uh grabs one of the female frogs i knew
i knew the frog so i know this is a
female
and all all the talking in the landscape
stops all the males stop talking and
they all kind of everyone kind of slinks
off
and this boa kind of chews on the frog
for 10-15 minutes spits it out
this frog then goes on to become a
mother because i'm tracking her she's
tattooed i know i
see her engage in courtship and lay an
egg and
feeds her tadpoles and she she she ends
up fine
and this boa is no longer around after
that day
learn its lesson but that's one time
yeah that's one time i've got one
anecdotes fascinating but it is actually
a natural history note and i don't know
herpetological journal of herpetology
something yeah
um so these things do still exist but
they're and they're rarer
and they're not looked at with the same
kind of reverence that
um a database paper is but
from the point of view of actually
understanding nature
man give me a natural historian who
knows what they're doing any day right
these these people have understood
something deep and
um oh it's dan jansen the famous
tropical biologist
who once said um a biologist dies with
90
of what he knows right takes it to the
grave
and this is unfortunate because in some
sense what a biologist accumulates over
or a naturalist accumulates over a
lifetime of watching creatures is really
very valuable stuff and it's just
impossible to record all of the things
that you've come to understand by all of
the anecdotes you've encountered
absolutely i mean it's actually part of
probably a small part but part of why
you and i find this
situation that's going on outside right
now so troubling
that um we both uh
create sense of our world by going out
into it and reflecting on the changing
of the seasons
and the plants and the birds and and you
know everything that's happening just in
our immediate vicinity
and being really unable to spend more
than a few minutes outside even while
masked
we don't have any n95 masks but even
while masked without feeling you know
quite at risk at the moment puts us such
a remove
from an ability to interact with
anything that isn't
us or what we've created right here is
uh incredibly restricting
yeah it is it's turned us it's turned
our world into an all social one which
is something we seek to avoid most of
the time not that we avoid all social
stuff but we avoid because we don't like
each other very much
now we avoid the complete socialness of
the world and um anyway it's been
enforced by stock
yep all right um
do you have any left-leaning critiques
of candies how to be an anti-racist kids
element my kids elementary school
emailed about staff commitment to equity
and anti-racism
i only hear bad but my feeds trend
conservative i won't support the
ideology with my dollars by buying the
book to verify
yeah i've i've um i've mentioned it a
couple of times and i don't remember
which episodes but it's going to be
fairly recent probably in the 40s
i've talked about some of my objections
to his book and
i have not been reading it for the last
few days but i got about halfway through
and i intend to finish it and provide
more um
more formal critique like i did for um
deangelo's white fragility but the main
one
i guess is that he sets up a false
dichotomy
he um coins a term anti-racist
he defines it to mean
those who seek equality of outcome and
he then redefines racist to mean
anything that's not anti-racist which
means
you are racist in his worldview if you
do not seek equality of outcome
and equality of outcome is um you know
broadly understood at least it was until
yesterday
academically speaking uh to be a goal
that is neither honorable uh nor liberal
nor
obtainable so um he's setting us up for
failure
and um you know what what i've said is
i'm anti-anti-racist and no that doesn't
make me racist
yep um yes it
let's just put it this way it's a pity
in some sense that you don't have a copy
i understand why i don't want to buy a
copy but the uh
the illogic that is apparent as it
proceeds is so obvious that you know
it's not a
liberal or conservative objection it's
just an objection on the basis that this
doesn't add up
yeah no and um i mean i should save this
for when i
when and if i do do the formal takedown
but um
there's a um
there's a point in chapter 10 where he
reports on himself in college candy does
as frankly such a racist
that he believed enough to say to his
college professor
that he'd figured out was wrong with
white people and that the problem is
that white people are aliens
and his professor to his credit says are
you high i mean he doesn't say that but
you know what is
wrong with you and um and candy sort of
resolves oh yeah
i guess it doesn't make sense i guess we
can breed together like this is this is
the rejoinder from the professor
you read it to me and unless i
misunderstood it the professor
tells him that can't be right because
white people can interbreed right i
can't take steps
so that's what i meant to convey just
now well
what i take out of it is that kendy
didn't get there on his own
no he did not how could you not and not
only did he not get there on his own
he's okay 20 year old college student
but he wrote it into this book and this
isn't his first book right this is his
latest book
and he'd already had a bestseller i
think so this is some
this is some crackpot racism that is
proudly in this book on how to be an
anti-racist
but um but because he's redefined racist
and anti-racist it's not racist
to be racist yeah wow
yeah yep yeah
your point about cuties being a book is
interesting but as soon as it becomes a
screenplay everyone involved becomes
suspect
yeah every 11 year old who auditioned
now has an audition tape of performing
those movements that will now last
forever
yeah that's true yep
what i did wonder how old the actual
actresses were not that it makes any of
this better
no um it would make it better if they it
doesn't make it a lot better right but
if they
make it a little bit better right but
the thing is they were so
young they couldn't possibly have been
adults
yeah so it can't be fully better yeah
um no no no way does it get
anywhere close to yeah not that it would
be okay from the audience perspective
and frankly you know as i said before i
don't think it's even okay from the
perspective
of um you know titillating a bunch of
old people
but uh still it might be
okay with respect to the fact that an
adult is allowed to make a decision to
be in a
role like this um and then it becomes
troubling from the point of view of the
people selling this thing and the
audience but
yeah but it wasn't even that yeah
would you agree that early homo sapiens
evolutionaries
having a hard time speaking today would
you agree that early homo sapiens
evolutionary success
was due in part to our skill in
addressing immediate threats like wild
animals etc
how has that played out and how does it
affect our ability to address climate
change
certainly the ability to deal
with immediate threats like wild animals
is a prerequisite to our success but i
think
to the extent that you mean uh
evolutionary success what you mean is
our disproportionate evolutionary
success
uh wild uh wild animals are not a
sufficient explanation
because a predatory ones are
sufficiently um rare
that they they just simply don't explain
why
you know humans got so much um smarter
and more capable than other creatures
that also have to deal with predators
yeah known at the point i mean this is
probably a
level of sort of semantics that it was
not intended by the question but if
we're talking about early homo sapiens
as opposed to early hominins that have
split from the chimp lineage but aren't
yet fully homo sapiens
by the time we're homo sapiens we've
already gone far down the road we've
already
we've already mastered fire uh we
um you know a million and a half years
ago ish and homo sapiens are newer than
that i think
homo sapien sapiens is newer than that
um and we're already in this
well in this sort of um
cycle that dick alexander describes
between
ecological dominance which is a kind of
addressing immediate threats like wild
animals
and the intergroup
uh competition which which dick and you
and i have argued is going to become
more and more important as we become
successful in
um dominating arcology um so it's really
you know
the thing that is more likely to have
um accompanied our for instance rapid
brain growth to you know bring you at
the body size ratio
brain to body size ratio growth and
specifically growth of the prefrontal
cortex
um has to do with the with the social
stuff
yeah as well i wouldn't say the social
stuff i would say it has to
do with other humans as
both opportunities and hazards and and
and uh being able to locate yourself on
a timeline
and think back and reflect back and
learn from and project forward and
imagine
and build narrative about both past and
future all of the tools that come along
with predicting what other creatures
whether
human creatures are going to do for the
purpose of either
partnering with them or challenging them
all of which
seem to be kind of focused in again
prefrontal cortex
which again is also not
fully developed until um seems to be
current neurobiological models suggest
until people are in their early 20s
which is yet another reason not to
imagine that children are adults and
have all the capacities of adults and
should be allowed to make decisions like
uh become hypersexualized or take
exogenous hormones to change their sex
etc
joe rogan while speaking with tim
kennedy yesterday
in different parts of the conversation
endorsed both tulsi gabbard and dan
cronshaw for president
what level of conversation have you had
with rogan about unity 2020
um i
have to keep people's identities
out of the discussion um
i suppose i could change their names to
protect the awesome
but the problem is this is a very
complex puzzle
and lots of in order
to solve the overarching puzzle of how
do we get from here to
actual leadership in the white house
many people
have to confront their own uh
obstacles their own social puzzles and
so anyway
it's you know is it a mexican standoff
is it um the penguins waiting at the
side of the
um the ice flow in order to
have someone that gets eaten exactly i
don't know
what the right metaphor is but the point
is actually
what we're looking for is the thing
that catalyzes the change in which a
bunch of other things can fall into
place
and
here's the thing if you're rooting for
unity 2020 you don't want me to tell you
you want me to leave people as safe
to contemplate things as possible which
leaves me
being far more ambiguous than i would
like good how can we know whom to trust
as a source for climate science
skeptical of everything help love you
both
yeah uh as you should be skeptical of
everything
and how can we know whom to trust as a
source for climate science
this is a tough question and i don't
know if you have any
names i don't actually have any names
that i trust i just know that
there are there are honorable and
dishonorable climate scientists
out there as they're honorable and
dishonorable everything's out there
and um because there is a conclusion
that is now
the the thing that is accepted it's
harder to
uh publish evidence that countervails
uh the conclusion that said the
conclusion has so much support
the broad conclusion that anthropogenic
climate change is happening
from so many different kinds of evidence
across so many different kinds of both
empirical and modeling evidence
that broadly speaking my my
doubt of that conclusion is near zero
but any individual result i am
highly skeptical of even more so than of
any other scientific result
because it's become so politicized and
i'll just tell i'll tell an anecdote
an actual story here um back when we
were professors at evergreen
i was on a hiring committee to hire
a climate scientist and one of our
finalists
so academic job hires you do
you pull three people to the short list
and you do
a couple day interviews on campus with
them and because it was climate science
we dragged these people out into the
woods and walked around the forest with
them and talked with them
one-on-one and um i was asking one of
their candidates
um one-on-one
about a paper that he had published and
asked him why in the methods he had
talked about
having used five models and it was you
know like all these papers that had like
20 authors on it or something
um why there had been five models that
were discussed
in the methods but only one of them
reported in the results
and he laughed as if i was joking
and i pursued it and then he said well i
don't i don't know that's you know
that's not my that's that's not what i
do
and i thought okay you know your name's
on this paper you're trying to get a job
um doing exactly this work and you have
no idea what justification there is
for having said that you had put your
data through five models but only
reported on one
that sounds like a replication crisis
waiting to happen and know the guy did
not get the job
but i i worry that that happens too much
um with the giant caveat like i started
with
that um throughout since before this is
politicized
and um across all sorts of domains of
types of data
including places uh where the scientists
aren't calling themselves climate
scientists
uh the uh the conclusions overwhelmingly
lead
to the result the data overwhelmingly
suggests
the conclusion that we are plummeting
towards anthropogenic climate change
that may at some point become
irreversible
um i would say james hansen i find
him trustworthy as a human being i would
say i don't trust
the models it's too easy to lie with
models if you put enough factors in them
you can make them mirror
any behavior without doing so because
they actually
match the uh the causal element however
easy to be a verificationist
models yeah it is um models um
can be used to predict things that you
might go check empirically but they
can't be used as an empirical
check but what i would say is
the that which we know for sure is
already enough to worry um a great deal
um co2 and methane trap
heat from the sun we've known this for
more than 100 years
the fact that both of those
molecules are rising in their density in
the atmosphere
also known to be true that that will
have some effect
is certain how much the effect we can
disagree because it's in a complex
system however
the important thing to track is that the
um the danger that one hits a threshold
point
at which for example the release of
frozen
methane clathrates from the arctic kicks
us into a phase in which we no longer
have any control
over temperature because you get a
positive feedback
where the temperature goes up that
unfreezes these frozen methane molecules
they are quickly released that raises
the temperature further which unfreezes
more and you get a positive feedback
that thing is not something you need to
detect from here
in fact you won't detect it until it's
too late right you can detect that there
are
these bursts of methane in the arctic
which we've now seen what we don't have
is really good baseline data on whether
that's happening all the time but there
is reason the yamal craters which i
pointed to
in siberia tell us that there are new
geological processes going on that
appear to be the result
of sudden releases of methane so what we
know is
there's a whole hell of a lot of methane
up there that could come
flooding out all of a sudden and could
take this question entirely out of human
control
right we don't know where that threshold
is it could could happen this evening
okay the the fires could be the thing
that do it right the release of carbon
from these fires
no idea where we are relative to that
threshold we know that it's out there
and um you know the day that it happens
it's not going to make the news nobody's
going to know that it happened but
there's a day at which this no longer is
under human control
so the point is given what we can say
for sure
the rational course is to say we are
playing with something very dangerous
the downstream consequences are
potentially absolutely catastrophic for
humanity
the solutions to these things are likely
to be highly generative
now here's the hitch if we were to solve
these problems
it would threaten the business models of
many established businesses
that's why we don't do it it's not that
it would make life horrible
for us to solve these things in fact
speak a little bit more so
you you hid you you buried a little bit
you said
um you know solving these problems could
itself the solutions could be generative
yeah like the solutions could actually
be good
for individual humans and the economy
what it won't be good for
is the established uh
organizations that have already made a
business in the old economy
right and in fact you can see this by
projecting backwards
um we've been talking about um you know
carbon tax
forever right a substantial carbon tax
now carbon tax has a cost an economic
cost it's substantial
but if 25 years ago or 30 years ago we
had seen this coming
and we had instituted a moderate tax
then which had driven
the innovations in battery technology
that we have seen
right all sorts of things that we all
regard as awesome
about the modern world would have
happened earlier that's what regulation
is supposed to do
right incentivize you to limit the next
the negative externalities that you
impose on the world right now the key
thing would have been and frankly we
were the country that dragged our heels
but the key thing to do would have been
to partner with other nations so that we
would not have been
at disadvantage for instituting that
carbon tax we could have had that
the cost um distributed in a fair way
so the point is innovation of a kind
that's great right you don't want to
breathe
exhaust right frankly um i was using an
electric chainsaw
just early this week electric chainsaw
it's pretty darn good
right it's not loud it doesn't put out
exhaust there are all sorts of
advantages and the point is
it hasn't been plausible until recently
because the battery technology has been
lagging so
if you can solve the economic
competition problem and you can get
everybody to
share their bit of the burden and you
are not
constrained to protecting currently
successful businesses you can do great
things and so
were we to address climate change it's
getting late but were we to address it
we would be living in a time when there
was plenty to do for innovators
because we would have to figure out how
to do lots of things that we already do
in some new and better way
and so the point is that's a lot of good
jobs yeah um
so anyway that's the pitch
let's try to get through a few more of
these before sweat switching
hypothetical for a thousand generations
a lineage of isolated humans wore
masks to hide from natural ills we did
not
we experienced all else the same we meet
them
their immune systems are stronger or
weaker than ours
well i hesitate with these stronger or
weaker immune system things but i think
in some sense
we know the answer here because the
germs in guns germs and steel
are the result of the fact that um
europeans
who came to the new world
were in some sense the beneficiaries of
confrontations with germs that they had
already had
and the reason that it was europeans who
had those confrontations with germs
was that the domesticable animals were
highly concentrated
in asia and because um
asia is uh it is
longitudinally laid out the migration of
those
animals into europe was unimpeded
and so the point was it was the close
contact with
pigs and cattle and other large
domesticable creatures
that caused europeans to have already
had experience that made them durable
with respect
to many germs so most germs and the most
deadly ones
uh impacted uh natives of the new world
um rather than conquistadors having
brought back deadly diseases from the
new world
yeah um so i mean there's two there's
two questions
in one question here and you can't you
can't do both at once because you have
to control for one
and um obviously it's a hypothetical
that can't be done but
um so you know old world meets new world
is
um you know a story of allopatry um
how you know could we ask this question
with sympathy which
you know to say um two populations
living side by side
one of whom is masked one of whom is not
uh
wherein they are being exposed to the
same stuff
except the people with masks are
presumably getting exposed less
what what then might be the distinction
after a thousand generations between
simply being exposed to
fewer airborne and aerosolized pathogens
versus more um
i could i could see it going either way
frankly it depends on exactly what
pathogens
were were met right like the pathogen
the deadly pathogen
uh that uh that you are saved from
because you're wearing a mask that
um otherwise wipes you out is obviously
you're better off if you're masked
over a thousand generations uh
protecting yourself from every single
thing
that is that is out there might make you
less resilient
when um something flips a
a vector model for instance you know it
moves into say
uh contact uh transmission rather than
aerosol transmission i don't think so
and the reason i don't think so is
because of carrying capacity
so if you've got these two populations
let's make them simpatric so they're
living in the same place
but you expose one of them to more
pathogens
and some of them die that's selection
for immunity and it will leave a
population that has that immunity in its
wake whereas the unexposed or less
exposed population will have undergone
less selection
so it's not just the immunity that comes
from the individual having encountered
the pathogen that informs their immune
system
it's this selection that favors immunity
towards those pathogens so by the same
logic that if you don't finish your
course of antibiotics the bacteria that
you leave are stronger and more
resistant to antibiotics in the future
the population that was uh
that was what not wearing the masks or
wearing the mask which way did your
story go the population that was not
wearing the masks will be stronger
at the end of that selective yes that's
that i mean so that's consistent i think
with um
what i was saying as well um so what
that
you know the the obvious place to go
then if i if we were in conversation
with with jeffrey who
who asked no it's different um with
michael who asked the question
would be okay then at what time scale
does mask wearing makes sense
like if if if at a thousand generation
time scale
um mass squaring might make um
a population weaker at what time scale
doesn't make sense
and i think part of the answer is going
to be um that for
individuals no no individual wants to
die of this thing
so at the population level you might end
up with a stronger population
but individuals all want to survive
right and so really what you're
comparing
is for the individual the cost of
getting sick
and the risk of dying from being sick
versus
the cost of um being naive
and naive to the pathogens to the
pathogen and the problem is
that the benefit to being naive to the
pathogen is effectively zero
um yeah so um the benefit of being
not sick is substantial so and that fits
with this
um sort of filling the bucket model of
exposure right you don't
you're not actually looking for zero
exposure at all
yep you're looking for a little bit of
exposure
occasionally over time such that
your immune system can can
maybe you know taste it and get a sense
of what it is
well you know i see a lot of people
playing with this idea that
low exposure to kovid for example might
produce some sort of immunity it's very
hard to demonstrate that this is true
of course um but it's it's plausible
and it's consistent with the idea that
apparently i don't i
don't have it pulled up so i can't show
you guys um but there's some recent work
suggesting that mask wearers
um mask squares compared to non-mask
squares and otherwise
um identical situations um have lower
uh have less severe symptoms when they
contract covid
and so that again is suggestive of the
sort of density dependent model
of virulence of the disease
okay critical race theory is spreading
rapidly through public school systems
corporations and even military schools
what does the united states look like if
these advocates get what they want
wait um it kind of looks like the
streets of portland
well it looks like a failed state
because we know that this is not a
proper recipe for being able to compete
with others and therefore anything
that succumbs to this will be vulnerable
in competition to anything that resists
it and that goes for nations
any nation that doesn't do this will be
an advantage over nations that do this
any school of engineering that doesn't
do it will produce
you know higher quality graduates etc so
um
seems pretty straightforward
all right um several more um
before we switch because many of these
are comments love you both would be
awesome to see brett and eric host a
round table with pro
trump libertarians such as candace owens
and stephon molyneux
to both steel man the cases for and
against as well as sow seeds to
hashtag heal the divide
i'll just let you let you grimace at the
screen and go on to the next one well i
get into trouble when i talk about
candace
um i don't trust candace i don't i don't
think
let me be careful about this many of the
things candace says
are right the question is why does
candice say them
and um i would love to believe that
candace is growing up and
becoming more nuanced but i don't really
see that
i think the best model to describe left
versus right is as explored versus
unexplored territory
conservatives so but except that's
reversed i think so
i'm going to read it the way i think
this person means it i think the best
model to describe left versus right is
as
unexplored versus explored territory
conservatives seek to preserve what's
established but can sometimes stagnate
whereas liberals push new bounds but
sometimes go too far
and that's i think that's quite right
that's quite good
um uh a
comment please talk with david friedman
law professor economist theoretical
physicist
oddly shunned by other libertarians
because he's such a principled
scientific thinker well that's a claim
maybe that's why he shunned
could be tragically underappreciated
genius needs to be part of the
conversation
i don't know the name do you know him no
okay last question here and then we'll
skip to the ones from this hour
do western states need to radically
change their forestry management to
combat the symptom of climate change
or will that just make it worse are we
missing pragmatic leadership versus just
blame games
uh yeah there's a lot of room for
clever improvements on what we've got
and unfortunately we have a dearth of
leadership and
possibly a dearth of insight where it
needs to be
but yes we could be doing a whole heck
of a lot better yeah
uh so zach i don't see a line here but i
think i'm at 30.
is that right
no i think i think i got it um
um yeah so the militant moderate is sort
of filling in for us here on when joe
rogan in episode 1535
says that he likes tulsi feels like she
was canceled by the dnc and then says
later i love dan crenshaw that's another
guy who should run for president
yeah tulsi and dan that's a cool idea
yeah why have i heard that before
with new waves of immigrants
um with new with new waves of immigrants
the first mixed couples seem to be
newcomers men and women who've been on
the territory longer a generation later
couples of newcomers
are couples are newcomers women and
established men
is that a pattern and if so how would
you explain it
so um i'm gonna this
this is unintentionally sort of
telegraphically written
um or telepathically written um
because of the limits on characters um
but the question is
arguing i believe is the observation
is that new in new waves of immigrants
when you have couples
uh between the newcomers and the
established people and i don't know if
this means established people from
the immigrant country or from the new
country
early on the mixed couples seem to be
the men or the newcomers and women
who've been on the territory longer
and then later on a few generations
later
when it's mixed couples it's uh women
who are new
and men who have been on the territory
for longer and
wait i'm i'm confused by what you said
and i
i don't quite get it when you have
a an immigrant population the initial
couples tend to be mixed couples
right those couples tend to be
resident men and newcomer women yeah but
i think
actually it means um from the old
country but they've just been there
longer
so um not resident of you know if we
were talking about for instance
jamaican immigrants to the u.s right um
the claim
isn't uh american
women and jamaican men it's the other
way it's no
it's jamaican women from three
generations ago who've been here for
longer and then newcomer jamaican men
so it's not about um you know
european descended americans it's about
um
it's about the immigrant population in
all cases but how long you've been in
country
so i don't think i get it then um i
understand the question but i i don't
and i've seen that i did see this
question once before um on our private q
a and i didn't
i didn't go to it because i don't
recognize it as a pattern
so i would want to um
i would want to see some evidence of it
actually being a pattern before i
tried to do some sort of like an
adaptive arm waving explanation for why
it might be true because it's never
occurred to me that it was true
and i'm not saying it's not i just have
never seen it um
and i've never i've never thought to
look for it nor seen it before
i think your interpretation is wrong i
think what it means
is when you have an immigrant population
to an existing population that
the first couplings interracial
couplings will tend to be
those men who are from the
home population and women who are from
the immigrant population
you disagree that that's the i think
you've got it backwards so i think
that's the
i think that's the way it is and i think
that no i think so there's two different
possible interpretations i don't
so you are i just don't think we should
spend more time here but i think you've
got it backwards from what she has said
here
and then there's an interpretation that
you and i have different that's it's
about
um immigrant men versus um
native women versus immigrant men versus
longer ago immigrant
women um so that's the point of
disagreement between you and me but then
i think you just sort of reversed the
hypothesis here in addition so i think
we need more clarification and
even just evidence because the idea of
trying to come up with why a pattern
that may or may not exist
does exist is not maybe dangerous but
kind of fruitless and not that useful in
exercise
i would say supporting the duopoly
creates a dystopian future
where evil robots rule the land they
can't master time travel but they can
make technology glitch
get a flux capacitor and your problem
will be solved you're welcome
or a p-38 modulator unit what
we could get one to blow up the earth um
oh is that
is that from bugs bunny mars the marvin
the martian
yeah um right yeah uh or flux capacitor
would be all right it seems like that's
probably more likely to be available yes
while we were on the glitch question
several people suggested that we get a
um
why am i forgetting the term for it yeah
spectrum analyzer but
uh what what are the details of the
object that we need to buy
um if you know please put it in the chat
you can just put it in chat because zach
i think is looking at the chat
at the moment yeah um
given escalating strife is it possible
for the
united states to consciously uncouple
and form separate entities and countries
a la the ussr
love you guys okay you made me laugh by
using consciously uncouple here
um can the u.s consciously uncouple i
don't think so
no that's that's the biggest problem
here is that there's just no
geographical resolution to be had which
doesn't mean that it won't come apart
into
i mean there have i mean there's there's
always talk about california seceding or
the west coast is eating or texas
seceding
um yeah the cities can secede from the
states
right like except what is the west coast
the seating going to look like because
actually other than
a 50-mile strip along the coasts um the
politics of
um inland west are very different from
coastal west
for instance urban and rural so i think
the point is
sorry that that dog ain't gonna hunt so
uh we need to figure well it ain't
fair enough yeah so uh i i do
think we simply need to figure out how
not to go down that road because anybody
who's imagining that we're going to
get some kind of uh workable divorce out
of this
is missing the geographical point
have you heard the song the greatest
show on earth by nightwish
it is about evolution and features
dawkins i have not
have you nope okay uh masters and
physics student here
brett is there any way to nudge your
brother into publishing for rigorous
scrutiny
his geometric unity love from texas
um there are those
who could but they are not
of this earth
now look the dude wants to publish
he does um he's busy and there are
uh hazards in the way but um to the
extent that there is hunger for this
thing i think it would nothing would
please eric more than
than to publish this stuff and so i i do
i
i expect to see it soon because i think
the
uh the world is becoming more hospitable
to the possibility
of such a thing emerging from uh the
quadrant that is airing
the whole family's on the podcast says
someone
um yeah we got we got a substantial
representation here we got half of the
of the organisms who have names who live
in our house
on air ish the dog's below our feet here
and fairfax is in my lap
uh
did i get that right yes half there are
eight of us who live here
for non-human animals and four humans
thoughts on disney
thanking government agencies responsible
for propaganda
hiding remind me how to pronounce this
oh word
spelled right right um we are camps in
there
i don't even know how to pronounce this
disney film milan millen milan
we lived in michigan for a while and
they pronounced milan mylon
so now whenever i see this word i have
no idea and i don't think that's how the
disney films
either pronounced saline celine
or something like that yeah i think it's
mulan actually which is not what this
word says
okay so i don't know how to pronounce
these words anyway but i'm a speller and
so once i don't know how to pronounce
them and they're not spelled right i'm
just like all bets are off that's my
excuse
the question is basically do you have
thoughts on disney thanking government
agencies
um who are responsible for propaganda um
hiding these camps in credits of some
film
also are there any meaningful
differences
between the chinese communist party and
nazi germany at this point
they both seem to have ethnic
concentration camps centralized
autocracies and are expanding along
questionable claims of historical ethnic
ties
example includes uh examples including
mongolia and indian border currently
so i don't i don't really know anything
about the disney story i've sort of
heard the memories of it but i just
can't speak to that
what about ccp and and nazi germany yeah
i don't think we want to leap to the
nazi comparison
too early the fact is um
we do not as far as i know have evidence
of the systematic extermination of the
weaker
we have evidence of concentration camps
we have evidence
of organ harvesting for sterilization
so these things are really really
terrible without rising quite the level
of the nazis systematic extermination
of jews homosexuals
jehovah's witnesses gypsies
right um so
that's not to i mean look this shows the
signs of
a situation that does head that
direction um
but let's you know if we leap to that
conclusion too early then we lose the
ability
to level that charge when it is
apt so there's plenty of room for evil
below that threshold
yep so i can't tell if this is our
screen
or something doctor
can you figure out what that says
yeah so i don't know if that's supposed
to be an s might be an s
that's so in which case would be dr su
doctor who
with a maybe that's just supposed to be
a diacritical mark and of course
you youtube won't allow that doctor
someone who sue said on jre
equality does not mean symmetry so that
is
absolutely true that has me rethinking
my views on feminism
um according to you what is the equality
that you should aim for
could people then argue women don't
deserve certain rights because you don't
because you don't have certain
capacities as men
so i think equality under the law
and equality in terms of outcome and
ability
are different and uh we
are you know a liberal worldview
democratic worldview
suggests that equality under the law is
something that we should all have
and that we must strive for a hundred
percent that is a place where equality
of outcome is
absolutely desirable and um should be
what we are striving for
that does not presume though and it
should not
presume that it means that we are
actually the same
uh and so uh
well there's a lot more to say here but
i don't know if we can get in the weeds
here a little bit
um i am not sure that i agree that
equality under the law is a quality of
outcome i think it's actually a cryptic
form of opportunity
the law is protecting the opportunity
and is the
is the balance of the law the blind
justice
that distributes the opportunity that
comes from the legal protection
yeah so i would say you know it's easy
to
deal with uh equality of opportunity as
a cliche
um but i think i think the point is
that is in some sense the opportunity we
are talking about
being equalized but there are two
components right
it is important that no group have an
advantage
at the level of opportunity and there
are many groups that do have advantages
at the level of opportunity
though how that advantage is passed on
and all these things are
murky but it is also important that
opportunity
itself be substantial rather than
trivial right so there's a question of
how much opportunity and there's a
question of where
it is and we want to
increase the amount of opportunity and
decrease the level of its concentration
and i think
you know whether it's exactly equal it's
never going to be
but how the
unfairness is distributed is should be a
focus it should be distributed as evenly
as possible
and the opportunity should be as broadly
distributed as possible
good um wow
i can't even get to my trackpad now uh
what is the relationship between
evolutionary biology and morality
what universal moral taboos or ethical
truths are rooted deeper than
culture well i would say
rooted deeper than culture is not what
you're looking for culture is
just as biological as genes it is a
separate mode of transmission
and
morality is effectively it
is a product of evolution we know that
it's a product of evolution because
behaving morally
is costly in obvious ways relative to
the evolutionary goal of increasing
fitness
and so it must be paying its way somehow
that is to say fitness may not be
defined exactly as we expect it to be
and morality can increase overall
fitness
you know you could increase your
long-term fitness by
foregoing short-term fitness enhancing
opportunities for example
but basically the answer is going to be
rooted in trade-offs
i wrote a paper about this many years
ago i won't drag you through the logic
of it but
but for a lineage
moral precepts that result in long-term
enhancement of fitness
meaning persistence will be favored
and therefore will be inscribed in
culture
that's that's basically the model
you're an hour and 15 minutes okay
let's uh let's do a couple more okay
uh part one okay so we got two part
question here
uh jordan peterson said men use the same
circuit to hunt when looking
for mates dogs like toys that squeak
when they bite it makes them think they
made a kill
in one uncomfortable context it seems
women instinctively trigger this circuit
in a similar way by spontaneously
emitting dying prey animal noises
that sounds pretty ridiculous to me i i
have great respect for jordan peterson
and his thinking
and uh i don't i think he has been uh
i think the woke left has tried to drag
him through the mud and the woke left
has
merely ended up looking quite muddy and
ridiculous as a result
um but i and i'd like to see what he has
to say here but if he really says this
i just think he's wrong well i will say
the same circuit
right hunting for mates hunting for
print now i will say
one thing one sees
young women do is
squeal to attract attention so i don't
know that that has anything to do with
hunting
but it does have to do with hitting some
frequency that causes
attention to be drawn to them at some
moment when they are engaging in fact
this happens in cuties
right at one point which like i think
both of us are like oh god they're doing
that thing
right exactly yeah
okay um we need to follow up on the
black intellectuals episode you did
please make it happen
make it like a monthly or bi-monthly
thing thanks for the pod that's from moo
for me i'll move for you
that's a strange name um yes there is
something in the works
so uh sit tight i don't think you'll be
disappointed
okay um oh wake up hit the like button
there are two thousand people watching
let's go people thanks
thank you i didn't just make that up
hell yeah and thanks for having the cats
and dog on the podcast you are welcome
um okay one two more questions um
no three we'll end up with this one okay
uh why did heather immediately move to
cover the cat's butthole what evolved
imperative was behind that gesture
i just didn't think you needed to see it
yeah he keeps himself clean because he's
a cat but i just
don't think that's what i don't
understand what person wouldn't
pull the cat's tail down and point their
butt away from the
camera it seems to me like the right
thing to do yeah
yeah um okay do this one finish here
um pearl harbor was a mostly peaceful
japanese flyover
it's a great meme on twitter right now
complete with cnn chiron
sorry i just put my question okay uh
good that sounds that sounds appropriate
final question can you speak to the
issue of cova denial and delusion
amongst family members and friends
that is somehow if you are a family or a
friend you are not you are not an
asymptomatic and will not wear masks in
each other's presence
hopefully that didn't get cut off
there's the rest of a question that i
don't see anywhere here
so um how do you like how do you
talk to people who um imagine
i don't even know what the narrative
sounds like in your head but
um i know
i'm seeing a very dumb breakdown in
conversation
yeah which is the
i think it's the right has a point which
is
that how we respond to
this pandemic should be
sensitive to all of the costs including
deaths that will arise
because of lockdown for example
and that we are not doing a holistic
analysis we're missing how many deaths
will be caused by
economic failure blah blah blah all
those things right
this then results in a rejection of the
idea that we should be doing drastic
things because the death rate isn't what
we feared it might be
right i don't think the death rate is
where it's at at all
right so you know i saw somebody we
respect on twitter the other day say
you know the rate of death for
kids under 16 is below
some very low number tell me again why
schools
um are still happening remotely and the
answer is well
you know if kids can get it and they can
and they're going to bring it home
and they will and somebody else is going
to catch it
and they will and it's going to damage
their heart or their brain
then what is the cost of that
interaction so
that at least though is really complex
right so the costs of schools being
virtual to both the kids and their
social development
and the parents and their inability to
have their lives
is huge and um
the fact that kids themselves don't
appear to be getting sick is true
even though all of these other things
are true um
i i'm not sure where i fall
out on what i think should be happening
and very and i think it's different in
different parts of the country different
different parts of the world um but i
can tell you for sure that virtual
schooling is a farce
oh it is it's a farce right um and
um so you know what what are we doing
this question though
is both difficult but i think a little
easier which is um
it's not necessarily easier in the
moment um but
how do you talk to people you know
people in your circle
when like oh i finally get to see you
but actually given that we don't live
together
and aren't breathing the same air all
the time we either have to stay far
apart or mask
and be careful because why is it that
you imagine that you're
like why have you decided that um you're
inherently safe for me that's not your
decision to make
right right so i have been having these
conversations and typically i will take
somebody outdoors
to have a conversation and i'll say not
to beat them up behind the woodshed
those are different people we don't have
a wood shed that's part of the problem
oh right
um but i will take people outside and
i'll say
hey let's have this conversation outside
where covet does not apparently transmit
yet at least um the other thing that i
will say
when people are like you know isn't this
uh mass business silly i'll say you know
i think people have it wrong
you should see the a you should go to
the subreddit of
people who have tested covid positive
and look at the people who have
long-term symptoms that don't seem to go
away
you should also look at the data on
heart damage
and long-term brain damage and you
should realize that we don't even know
whether you get long-term immunity after
you've had this whether the thing might
reside in neurons blah blah blah blah
and so the point is you say all here are
all of these unknowns
now the question is what do we do it's
not clear to anybody because until those
unknowns are answered we don't know what
the costs are
but yeah you know it may be that
everybody
you know you make let's say that half
the people who got covid are going to
lose
a decade or more of their life that's
probably extreme but yep
but we don't know one way or the other
it could be a larger number and smaller
number of years
right seems more likely but but the
point is and
you know if you're going to get it every
five years
because it's going to circulate and your
immunity doesn't last what does that say
to us you know so
they're all of these things and from my
perspective i don't know how we get to
the conversation
which is let's talk about what we should
have done
right we should have really locked down
for a much shorter period of time right
we should not be dealing with schools
coming back
in virtual form we should have taken six
months later
six weeks and we should have done this
properly and we should have
put everything necessary to get highly
reliable testing so
the con the combination of a very
intense brief lockdown
followed by um very accessible high
quality testing would have been enough
and the point is somehow we're or this
even absent
super high quality testing uh pooled
testing
uh that allows you then you know at the
at the end of it like okay i
would say i think university of arizona
maybe is is
is testing their student population this
way and actually keeping numbers low
compared to like every other college
campus that actually has so by pool
testing you mean you pull a bunch of
people together and if anybody tests
positive then you do the fine grain so
it's like
like everyone being regularly tested a
lot you know frequently
but you know every test is like a hunt
inputs from 100 people
and you have to have very very low false
false positives for this to work
yes um but the false negatives don't
matter as much
because um well they don't matter as
much
so yeah any any positive you get from
that then you you know break it into
groups of ten whatever
i don't know exactly what the protocols
are but yeah um you actually can just
like
really quickly get through a whole bunch
of tests this way and
and rule out okay all you guys are safe
and you can like still be careful but
you can go about your business right
yeah but what i'm trying to get past is
the sense
that what has unfolded is a vindication
for the side
that wasn't all that worried about this
in the first place i am
you know if anything more worried than i
was because of all the things we don't
know and the fact that we
what we've learned is pretty frightening
even if it doesn't amount to
sudden death for people um so
the point is look i don't really want
responsibility for what to do now
i want to say what should we have done
then and who was saying that
why didn't we listen to those voices and
what are they saying now
right that that i think is what we
should be doing and it doesn't amount to
let's end this lockdown already this was
a false alarm because that's not that's
not what happened
yeah okay we're done except there's one
more comment that i think we need to end
on
which is quote i saw a moose in the
desert end quote
bartender i'll have what he's having
it's called a moose in the desert that
was basically my reaction when you came
home with the boys from that field trip
that you'd run with one of your classes
like we saw a moose at sun lakes sure
you did
and but i think that was the reaction of
the ranger too right you told the ranger
well
but but i still struggle with the
rangers reaction because
i saw moose in the desert i was with a
great number of people who also saw it
so i knew it wasn't a hallucination
y'all weren't tripping
we weren't tripping okay uh we were
field tripping but we weren't tripping
tripping and anyway
so saw the thing i'm a mammologist i
know a damn moose when i see one
so anyway i said to the ranger i didn't
know if this was the first time this had
ever happened i said to the ranger
i believe i saw a moose out at
deep lake and he says i don't think so
and um you know i
i said i feel pretty certain it was
there he said no
um and i said has there ever been one
here before he said it happens every now
and again
and it was like well if i just told you
i saw a moose and it happens every now
and again doesn't it stand to reason
that that was
the moose in question oh that's that is
a very surprising conversation
it was a very surprising conversation i
somehow i'm i'm somewhat traumatized by
the logic
it's like eight years later or something
yeah well every so often it gives me a
nightmare yeah
well all right i think we've come to the
end of another live stream
we will um try to be back tuesday i'm
not sure
um but if so it will be later because
zachary is now back in full-time virtual
school
full time our producer cannot be
producing until
um something like 3 30 pacific time in
the afternoon if we do come back
on tuesday in the meantime continue
consider joining the discord server at
either of our patreons
or getting access to the previous
private q and as on my
patreon and joining us for the next one
yes um again if you know what it is that
we need to use in order to sort out our
interference problem
i think everybody will be happier if we
can get to the bottom of this so
tell us what device that might be and
how much we need to spend to
to get it um please like subscribe
comment yep uh spread the word check out
the clips channel
pass along little bits that you think
might be worth other people seeing
yeah some clearer wishes for us
yes uh hope for the best with respect to
fire and smoke
and stay safe we'll see you next time
you